[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's chris mad dog russo host of mad dog
unleashed on siriusxm radio and he hosts
high heat on the mlb network
mad dog how are you hello danny boy how
you doing okay i'm doing okay uh we were
talking about
uh the world series and and i you know
i'm openly rooting for dodgers versus
the astros because the story line and i
totally agree totally agree but braves
fans are getting upset with me it's like
what do you have against us i have
nothing against you you're a good story
you had some great additions at the
trade deadline but you know freddie
freeman
like you're not we want star power or we
want revenge we want drama
and you know maybe we get astros in the
braves but do you get killed when you uh
are rooting for a storyline i do and i'm
with you a thousand percent you're right
on that's the best one um dodgers
houston i don't think we're going to get
it now but i think dodger juicing
uh would have been a superb series
dodgers look like they've run out of gas
you know their pitchers are tired
turner's hurt
uh give the braves a lot of credit last
night and then they jumped on them early
aursus is aureus is tired bueller was
tired so i mean i i don't know
i think the giants took a lot out of the
dodgers i think all year 106 wins five
games i think it took a lot out of la
and the braves are peaking at the
perfect time so i'm with you you're
gonna get probably and i think houston
will figure out a way to win a game at
home so i think you're gonna get houston
atlanta and you both you and i you know
much better than me about ratings that
is not going to light up america i think
if it went deep and you got a sixth and
seventh game i think those last two
games would be good but next tuesday
night in houston there comes atlanta
i don't know if uh the tv sets are going
to be turned on across the country so i
got to be honest that's just the way it
is but i do think it'd be a fun series
there'd be a lot of runs
good weather nice ballparks but the
world america dodgers astros we've been
a lot of fun yes fans get mad they think
if you go the other way that you hate
their team
just because you want to dodge your
astro thing dan doesn't mean you and i
hate the braves no we're looking at this
from a different perspective but the fan
thinks if you don't talk about their
team and their job they did well hold on
now that means you don't like atlanta so
you're an anti-brave guy which is not
the case we always look at momentum
we're trying to figure out momentum and
you would have thought maybe the dodgers
would wake up after bellinger's home run
mookie betts has the game-winning rbi
but what is the saying like momentum is
tomorrow's starting pitcher i don't know
if earl weaver uh coined that phrase but
how do you explain the dodgers lineup
that had two hits the starters had two
hits
i can't and not only that again against
the bullpen i mean so it's not like they
were facing uh you know
greg maddox uh circa night it's circuit
2 98th i mean i mean they were facing
obviously i i can't explain it um i
thought the dodgers were definitely
going to win last night i did not take
into account orisa's aureus might be a
little tired and he was
uh the braves jumped out two nothing you
can sense right away that the dodgers
were in a little trouble once they got
those two runs
um you know they had that one
opportunity and then of course he hit
the double play turner and he got hurt
in the bottom of the seventh inning off
the lead off single but you know you're
not going to come from 5-2 down too many
times in a row dan i mean the game the
night before i mean out of the out of
nowhere he hits a three-run homer in the
bottom of the eighth you're not doing
that every day and i'll tell you
something else and i did not take into a
take this into account so blame this on
me you know this is the third time now
the braves and dodgers have played in
the playoffs in the last three years
18 they played dodgers one and four last
year they were down three one and a one
you're going to beat the braves three
times in a row and then you're going to
beat the braves down 3-1
twice in a row
no you know the way sports go you know
sooner or later the tide's going to go
the other way so the dodgers look to me
be an exhausted team i think atlanta
will get by and i can't explain last
night i'm with you thought that that was
such a
huge joke on the night before that it
would be a carryover especially against
the braves bullpen it didn't work that
didn't work that's why we love sports it
didn't work out that way i'm watching
houston against the red sox and framber
valdez
is out there
and i keep waiting for the analytical
department with the astros to say well
you got to take him out
because he's gone more than four innings
oh my god he's gone more than five and
i'm going
like he's dealing
and and john smoltz even said you know
sometimes it's just your gut feeling
like you you ask your catcher
and you know you have different metrics
there but you're asking your catcher
you know
how does he feel how's he look your
catcher will be honest with you
but this somebody goes seven innings and
it's herculean i mean it it used to be
it was almost mandatory in big games i
totally agree i think that's hurt the
sport a lot nobody gets wrapped up to
see relievers pitch these games the
entertainment value see what baseball
has lost and they've lost the great
starter
trying to get through a lineup the third
time in a big game
you know verlander a few years ago
against the yankees in a in a game six
gibson against the yankees pick anybody
you want you lose that so what they do
is they bring in the anonymous relief
pitcher who nobody's ever heard of who
you can't pick out of a lineup oh and by
the way after he faces three battles to
bring another guy in to do the same
exact thing so the entertainment value
of this sport with a big star pitcher
imagine lebron if we took him out in the
fourth quarter because we feel that you
know the fourth quarter he's too tired
so we're bringing i mean
imagine if brady doesn't play in a
fourth quarter of a playoff i mean
that's what we've done with the great
pitcher but i agree with you about
valdez and give dusty credit bottom of
the fifth it's only one nothing
bottom of the fifth base hit hit batter
and he dusty goes out to the mounds and
you know nine times out of ten the
manager panics brings in the reliever
dusty basically tells them to settle
down four or five pitches later renfro
hits into a double play they get out of
the inning and in the top of the six the
astros scored three runs or whatever
they scored four or five right so uh the
it was a breath of fresh air watching
this kid pitch yesterday it really was a
breath of fresh air they needed that
start in a worse way but the the great
starting pitcher
that we all used to love you and i as
kids
siever seventh inning against rosen
bench
in the 73 postseason in game one is a
perfect example as it turns out those
two guys hit home runs off them but you
get you know what i mean yeah that great
hall of fame starter baseball no longer
can give you that and i think you and i
think that's a major problem with the
sport it's unfortunate that's the way
the data scenario you know you got the
kid riding the shrimp bike into the into
the offices right out of ucla
just wash his hair with the bruins
sweatshirt on and he tells uh you know
andy freeman andy look at this data
third time through the lineup against
this team that starting pitcher you know
gives up a 285 batting average let's get
the hell out of the game that might be
good for their you know for maybe the
front office it's bad for the
entertainment there's no question about
it but do you think and i keep bringing
this up where
somebody is going to be
have a counter attack an alternative
style
hit and run
uh
you know you're going to be
maybe in a bigger ballpark maybe you
steal bait putting pressure
that you must make something happen
every time you get to the it's almost
like patrick mahomes he's hitting home
runs but when you force him to hit
singles now you change the whole dynamic
the the titans run the football nobody
wants to face them in the postseason
does somebody does a baseball team say
let's take advantage of our ballpark and
play this style of baseball that will be
different than anybody else so you have
to deal with us as opposed to the other
way around 85 cardinals when they ran
all over the place with vince coleman
and everything that's another thing that
dusty did yesterday dan it was good top
of the sixth inning altuve walks
what's he do after that he steals second
base
and then they uh uh no
there was a play that he stole it wasn't
that one but there was a play yesterday
that he stole the bag which is right
after which was a tremendous move
because he caught the red side i thought
it was in the top of the six whatever
inning it was dusty put on a steel sign
and he got the bag stolen well that's
what it was he was running
on the ball that was hit the third base
endeavours through the schwerberg who
dropped it and 02 they ended up all the
way at third base
because he's running with the pitch and
bradley hits a little ball down to third
base
that kind of baseball we've missed it's
strikeouts or hit home runs where this
has been discussed forever and it's it's
unfortunate and the other thing that
that was surprising to me and i you know
think about it the ratings i get into
the ratings
tuesday night
that was a great baseball night
bellinger hits the home run
and then the red sox and astros it's two
it's one one and it's two one red sox
top of the eighth
those ratings for those games you would
think would be really good and they were
decent four million but the nba didn't
do that much worse
a matter of fact lebron and curry at 10
30 did like three and a half main and
the red sox astro game did like 4.2
wouldn't you think a baseball playoff
game in in our era would bury
an nhl or an nba regular season i know
it's lebron and curry but geez well i
guess
highest rated individual game in world
series history
you know what it is
uh yeah it's the red sox reds isn't it
in game six when they had 75 million
people watching it 1980 game six oh
that's the yeah you're right philly's
royals had a 40 rating yeah that's right
you had the reds against the red sox was
almost a 40 rating the dodgers uh when
they swept the yankees
um
in 60 in 66 63
1986
uh the most viewed game game seven 1986
the mets over the red sox that had a
38.9
so yeah those are monster monster
numbers where now you're getting a a you
know a 12
maybe
and you're happy with the uh 12. yeah
you know i i think baseball in each town
can produce that
the problem that baseball has
is that you know if the pirates are in
the world series the pirates locally
will get that kind of rating
but the problem is pittsburgh doesn't
care about dodgers braves
no they get no carryover in other words
and if the steelers are out
they care about green bay tampa
for they care about you know kansas city
and buffalo in the afc championship game
they're going to watch
the towns in which their teams have been
eliminated
they don't get into the next round when
their team isn't in it
and i think that kills the rating
because you know locally if your team is
in the postseason in baseball your
rating is going to be great they're
watching the games in boston houston
atlanta but when their team is out and
they're not in the postseason they'll
follow it
they know what's going on but they're
not going to sit there for three and a
half hours and watch the game
what about gambling
chris
they don't gamble who's gambling in the
base they don't gamble that much with
the baseball yeah i was wondering
it's not like the football yeah football
they gamble everything first quarter
second quarter points overs prop bets
catches by receivers you know half time
they do everything basically they don't
do that as much and i think that i think
you know i think that's a major factor i
don't think it's the local i think the
fan interest is great i just don't think
the fan interest once their team is out
of it there's no carryover while in
football there is and i think that hurts
and that hurts the sport right and i
don't know how you solve that how do you
solve that problem i don't know how you
solve it he's chris mad dog russo mad
dog unleashed on siriusxm uh that's
channel 82 and host a high heat on major
league baseball network had bob costas
on yesterday
and he was talking about gambling um his
dad of course used to be a bookie oh i
know and i and i said to him okay you
got one hall of fame vote pete rose
roger clemens barry bonds
you know who he took
uh
i i if he had one he should have taken
rose did he take him yeah
yeah rose bonds clemens
yeah uh i can buy that yeah i think the
same order see if you take bonds you
gotta take clemens so you only have one
it's you know they're both group bonds
and clemens with the same
steroid brush
so it's hard to differentiate yeah the
fact that rose
isn't in the hall of fame i i listen i
mean we all know that rose at times we
understand you know he's not uh a choir
boy we get that
and rose you know
uh you know it was bad what he did but
rose bet as a manager
not as a player
and we're putting him in a hall of fame
as a player plus rose never bet on his
team to lose
and if anybody thinks
it's the same thing they're nuts
either the 19 19 19 white sox
bet on their team the loose
rose never did
rose is too competitive to ever want to
lose
so he better so to me that's a huge
difference now i don't know how you feel
about it betting is bad anyway if you're
involved in a sport i'm not denying that
but there is a major difference you know
i'm going to throw the game to lose then
you know what i'm going to better myself
because i'm going to win there's a major
difference yeah but i can't put pete in
until i put shoeless joe jackson in
that's fair too i mean he had 375 in a
series where you know he was you know
reportedly took money i mean imagine if
yeah i imagine if he didn't take money
what he would have hit you know that's
an excellent point
an excellent point uh
joe jackson had a great world series the
problem is he took 500 bucks but he had
a great world series so how do you it's
very hard that is very very hard to
differentiate but listen does anybody
think that p rose and here's the other
thing that drives me crazy
we got everything from the big red
machine in that hall of fame
we got pete's cleats we got his bat that
he used to be ty cobb
we have everything that you want you got
the hitting streak when you hit from 44
straight everything you want about pete
rose you want his glove you want his
uniform you want
cleats you got everything you want by
pete rose oh but by the way we're not
going to put pete in so we can walk
through cooperstown and see everything
that has got paraphernalia that relates
to the big red machine and pete rose but
pete doesn't get a day i i i really i
mean but don't you think he's benefited
more chris by not being in the hall of
fame because if pete got in the hall of
fame
no one would care
he does keep his name in circulation
he's made more money by not being in the
hall of fame
you know you can make the argument yeah
because people are so curious and they
feel that but let's face it let me ask
you a question should people hall of
fame
i i view it as he he cheated in grad
school so i can't take away his
undergraduate degree until i i if i
think that he bet on baseball as a
player
then i would not have him in the hall of
fame
now i've said this before on my show
my bookie used to take some of pete's
bets when i used to bet
so i knew what pete was doing and how
frequent he was doing it and how bad he
was do i think that he bet as a player
absolutely is there any proof
no
not that i've heard but as a manager
i i can't take away what i saw on the
field i you know it's like reggie bush
with a heisman trophy
you know what he did off the field
he still won a heisman on the field you
can take it away he's still a heisman
trophy winner that's a good point and
pete i i just
i got to see him i grew up in cincinnati
i mean we loved pete you know we wanted
to wear number 14. we we slid head first
like everything about it i just
uh pete never read the room well chris
if he read the room he would have thrown
himself on the sword and said to bud
oh yeah oh he just needed to do this and
i've talked to commissioner selig about
it
i'm going to go through the minor
leagues on my own dime
and talk about the dangers of gambling
i'm i'm going to do that because you
know what i need to give back to the
game pete just never thought that he had
to lower himself and and i think he
would have gotten in or oh i agree that
you're right i mean if pete in 1990
threw himself at the mercy of the court
we would not be having this discussion
no we would not and pete didn't do that
and pete you know but i could also make
the argument it has been 30 years
yes he's 80 years old yeah
really i think he gets
i think it's posthumously chris if he
gets in it's going to be posthumously
well you know they didn't put george you
made a great point they never put joe
jackson in and he's been dead forever
1951.
south carolina so they didn't put him in
you know here's the thing that always
bothered pete i had him in studio a
couple years ago
that's fascinating you know when his kid
made his debut in major league baseball
you know they wouldn't give you the pass
yeah he had to buy a ticket yeah
no no hold on now i know it's pete's kid
pete also had money on the game though
chris
yeah
maybe he did oh keep stirring it up
there mad dog great to talk to you thank
you buddy that's uh chris mad dog russo
host of mad dog unleashed sirius xm
radio